welcome to Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and I'm also the director
of New York City's Hayden Planetarium at
the American Museum of Natural History
and I got with me my coat jet knives
that's right Chuck nice comic tweeting
thank you sir yes that is indeed correct
there you go that's up nice comment was
there a Chuck nice already taken
yes it was me or did you didn't like
myself enough to cancel that and so I
just started a whole new one all over
again Jeff nice calm in case you didn't
laugh at my tweet just remember that
it's truck night that's how that works
you're also host of a spin-off of star
talk that we're all quite proud of yes
playing with science laying with science
yeah because what happened was we had of
our guests or the portfolio of our
guests the the ones that were
professional athletes developed their
own following basically let's spawn that
yes to its own show I have spawned with
yes so and your co-host on that is is a
Gary O'Reilly who has a performer a
former professional footballer football
area for the UK Crystal Palace and very
cool and today we're talking about the
evolution of personal technology Wow
indeed
that's it that's a very rapid evolution
yes it is and I featuring my interview
with YouTube vlogger and all-around
sensation in this niche we have marques
Brownlee that's featuring my interview
kid yes that kid yes does all the
unboxing yes I love it yes and it's also
known online is what and mkbhd there you
go I love that kid there you go
featuring my interview with him cool
that was fun just cuz I feel like you
know okay go to bed now and say Pat your
back look like his father yeah yeah he's
got his own world like create his own
world he's big stuff now since I don't
have marginal expertise in this
generally we go out and find the real
expertise as we did today in studio we
have science and tech writer for the New
York
times and other outlets including wired
Clive Thompson Clive good to be here my
friend welcome that's great to be here
dude dude so you you you you have a book
from a few years ago yeah yeah smarter
than you think
yeah how technology is changing our
minds for the better
yes sir wow that is so counterintuitive
you are the only one this is making us
dumber if you need that book yeah all
right all right but we don't none of us
agree with whatever you could have
possibly put in there
so in my interview with marques Brownlee
he runs a YouTube channel mkbhd
yeah there's a YouTube channel 5 million
subscribers 700 million video views and
he reviews new tech and gadgets that you
might think of buying right or that you
already bought and then you learned you
shouldn't have so so any idea what makes
makes it so popular because I'm not a
first adopter so I don't I don't have to
chase the latest but see the unwrapping
so popular what is what you just said
I'm not a first adopter he is the first
to don't you read in in your cell
somebody has somebody's gotta be the
first the first of them that's what this
kid does and also frankly he's also you
know I think he's sort of an exemplar of
what's happening at this new generation
of sort of broadcasters are growing up
not on TV but on online and and they're
really I mean he's really good at it you
look at it it's like it's just
beautifully shot he's just oozing
charisma so in modern times one perhaps
shouldn't even make the distinction
between being on TV or being on one yeah
in a weird way may YouTube is such a
funny old phrase right because - I mean
who actually watching YouTube remembers
that's what yeah I barely do I've got a
called young kids in grade school middle
school and you know for them you know
what they watch where they learn things
from as YouTube like you know they not
once we got a TV box it hooked up to
YouTube it's just YouTube on TV like
there's no actual TV being walk
make the distinction that's right right
Leroy area so that's the that's an
emergent fact I think it's beyond just
not making the distinction because I
have also an 11-year old and he is
resistant to television right yeah the
fact that he has to do it on their time
and their schedule actually sit down in
front of a thing attached to the wall it
upsets you and there's also sort of I
mean I think there's kind of an
authenticity that comes or parents
authenticity hard to say how thick it
really is but from you know seeing
someone who looks maybe more like
someone you might actually know doing
this and you know like I might my kids
watch all these Minecraft videos and
someone doing minecraft and their little
box up in the corner showing them in
their crappy little room that's what my
son does there you go and my son know is
how to play that game better that's
right yeah right right
so the YouTube feels more authentic and
more you know like there's a real person
there then a very glossy TV show and
they get like 12 million on how to
execute some maneuver and that situation
right so I sat down with Marquez so he's
well known on the web of course and I
just asked him how he got started on
YouTube so let's check it out
okay Lee you've been doing this since
you were three years old or something is
that for a while I never guess more than
a majority of my life good most of your
life yeah so more than half your life
and how old you are now sound 22 you
getting old yeah I'll tell you yeah
we'll tell you how it happens later on
it's just downhill from 22 yeah so so
you're into gadgets yeah
into all kinds of tech I got into
cameras and I got into all the tech
around me and then this sort of emerged
into making videos about the tech and on
a youtube channel that's a hugely
popular place for people to go right and
it didn't start that way it started as
just me making videos for like myself
just to have that exists somewhere and
then slowly people started to discover
it and then it sort of grew from that
and so you would so it doesn't cost
money to review a gadget you got to own
the gadget right somehow obtain it right
so what how did you do what you do I was
in school so I was I was using a laptop
for school so I reviewed the laptop and
I reviewed a bunch of free software on
the laptop and then I started viewing
paid things that I bought
maybe the cooler for the laptop that's
the kind of stuff that got got you off
the ground and then you sort of proceed
to check out more elaborate or
extravagant things and then people come
to depend on you unless mark is it's
something you use as daily as like a
smartphone for example that's the kind
of thing you do actually put a lot of
research into and watch a whole bunch of
videos on before you actually buy it so
when did you realize you started having
a following I think one of the the
turning points is a video I did about a
web browser when safari by Apple came to
Windows I made a video about that woke
up the next morning and I had a couple
of thousand views from people who
weren't subscribed that was kind of a
lightbulb moment like oh people actually
kind of care about this timely
information and by then you had just
turned five years old 15 same difference
I just wondered did did did your parents
worry about you if you're just playing
with gadgets he'll never amount to
anything he's just playing with these
toys yes yes yes yeah it's one of those
I'm betting it's one of those things
yeah he'll never amount you know they're
shaking their hand as you're just
playing with your electronic toys just
editing a video doing nothing he's just
doing nothing such as the always the
case when the next generation defines
what the future will be so Clive how
would you distinguish your childhood
from his because you you grew or started
writing and you cared about the same
gadgets and software that he did but not
in that era that's right yeah that I
mean this is like you know I grew up in
the in the 80s and then when I get out
of college in the 90s there's no
smartphones yet there's barely an
Internet right there was like a lot of
these text BBS or how to invent it first
yeah absolutely
message boards yes yeah that's what it
was yes yeah so I kind of had them and
liked it so I could see the future
coming with message boards I could sort
of figure out what's happening right but
yeah my youth is very very different and
I think you know you you would have come
of age during the earliest cellphones
then correct you know I was 90s was no I
I was I was in May I was well into my
20s when that when the when the mobile
phones came out okay so our Mountain
exactly yeah the ones you can use to
deflect bullets yeah I know I
Mars exactly yeah yeah no I mean I think
it was very different and I think I
think there's some of the things I would
have liked about I mean I look at the
online world now and I think I wish I
had some of the stuff I was in a band in
high school right so you know we make a
we make a couple you know a small EP of
music who heard that no one so you will
be born fifteen years later yeah that's
really what's your sense and summer span
would have put the thing out on YouTube
okay so so I try to take a cosmic view
on these matters okay and I just try to
imagine in 20 years marques Brownlee's
saying gee I wish I was more than 15
years later alright because something
else what else would that would have
made some next generation even more
potent YouTube of the mind of the mind
yeah yeah hard you know USB you just
jack in and you close your eyes you
don't even have to close your eyes it
just sends it to implants it in people
and we're looking back in these days as
how how archaic they were yeah so so I'm
just curious the in terms of YouTube as
a site are there other sites now as I
understand it Facebook is now a huge
access point for videos I would say also
snapchat actually or snap as they now
call it it's a really big deal um there
are like they started this channel it's
kind of like you know where people do
like semi-professional videos but
there's people who have just kind of
blown up on on on snap I have trouble
calling it snap on snapchat that's
that's a very very big video area for
young people now to YouTube is still you
know the gorilla in the room but are
there others so snaps head snap snap
right crackle pop that's what I know
what I say snap but the snap the thing
is that it seems like all of their
technology they're they're quite
innovative yeah but it seems like all
their technology just gets stolen by
these other sites that's right yeah how
are they gonna stay in business I don't
know you could yeah because Facebook
basically Instagram essentially copied
everything they did and
now it turns out that instagrams blowing
up cuz people are doing that kind of
quick viral video thing on Instagram
that's a good question I don't know okay
okay if you don't know who what give me
the guy who does know it's so-so with
you know phones coming out and the next
generation of phones look pretty
expensive the next iPhone is gonna be up
there how influential do you think those
reviews are and people's buying buying
decision well I think they're awfully
big I mean like when I talk to people
and ask them how they learn about things
like I'll ask them and they're like yeah
that's all YouTube all YouTube like
they're they immediately go there to try
and figure out what something looks like
what it feels like what it works like
and whether or not they should spend
money on it so YouTube has become the
conduit for learning about something
before you buy it
absolutely so I asked Marquez to just
sort of reflect on how technology has
evolved over his short number of years
reviewing it so let's check it out so
you're you're 22 now
so in your long career as a reviewer
what what is what would you say change
most since you were 15 let's say or that
is impressed you most yeah for what has
changed I can I'll give two things one I
talk about a lot of handheld electronics
like smartphones tablets laptops
displays have impressed me a lot and the
quality and resolution Iger Smurfs
detail the Chris penis all that stuff a
lot in the last couple years and also
more recently cameras cameras and smart
phones cameras in laptops the the
front-facing cameras but especially in
smartphones have gotten a lot better but
the number one thing I'd say is the
displays and the quality of quality of
displays has enabled a whole industry to
land in that medium isn't that correct
yeah it's not just making what you saw
previously better yeah it is opening up
entire new industries is that a fair
statement virtual reality is an example
where you wouldn't you wouldn't have a
super high-resolution display right up
against her face with a lens to focus on
it to put you in another world that
would not be possible with the displays
four or five years ago because that
close to your
face the lower resolution would be
unsolvable to you is that a fair yeah
okay so we've crossed certain thresholds
of the device innovation yeah
Apple might use the term Retina display
to describe a display where the pixel
density is so great that your eye cannot
discern individual pixels pretty much
every phone has a Retina display at this
point where five years ago that was not
the case and even the photos you take
with the cameras getting so detailed in
such high resolution that again the type
of images you can take out of a camera
on your smartphone are often better than
something you get from a dedicated
camera like 7-8 years ago yes so Clive
what can you explain why this is
happening yeah I mean it's just demand
and supply right so one no I didn't know
the demand stuff that I'm buying now I
mean it's like oh my gosh I guess that's
kind of cool once people start once it
once the iPhone came out and people
realize that they want and yeah 10 years
ago right elephone comes out and they
don't want a little flip phone anymore
they want something as a screen on it
right so that produces an enormous
demand for those screens and over in you
know Asia the factories start working
and working working working the price
drops dramatically and so the high end
is always chasing more and more pixels
and more resolution and greater
brightness but even that has dropped and
dropped and dropped and dropped to the
point where like you know it's an
expensive part of the foam but it's it's
it's it's amazing how cheap you can get
really nice screens now over in a gym so
so I had now I have a nice screen but
like I said this I never would have
imagined using my cell phone saying yeah
I want to take a picture with myself
well I say Jim this was not an urge yeah
that's right I don't think anybody had
that urge you know no I think what might
have driven that I thought they were
forcing it on me initially yeah they did
right remember and I think what did it
was a Believe It or Not apps with the
advent of apps in these photo apps that
allowed you to do your own little like
photo shopping and to manipulation and
then post them you it's like yeah I mean
I think in many ways a tipping point was
probably Instagram right so that was the
first first thing where you could take a
picture and you could do put a filter on
it and make it
prettier than what you did right and
this was an intentional thing that Kevin
Systrom the guy that invented it was
talking about with his girlfriend when
he was designing it about sharing photos
and she said to him they were talking
about and she was like the problem is I
don't want to share my photos they don't
look as good as yours he's a big you
know analog camera guy and and he said
well that's because I'm using all these
these films that produce these lovely
filtering effects he said well you need
to put some filters in that thing lo and
behold that's exactly what work because
you could take pictures make them look
pretty instantly share them that took
off are we gonna go up against is there
some Moore's law of personal technology
yeah there is and it's not gonna end
well first of all guys let me just say
that there are some people who may not
be familiar with what yours lies I mean
I know other people might but what is
Moore's law and brief Moore's law is the
observation
you know several decades ago that
computer chips were getting basically
twice as fast every 18 months right and
that's because they could make the
components smaller and smaller and
smaller they are now at the atomic level
those wires are so tiny you can't make
him any smaller that is what's called
the end of Moore's law
so will the devices stop hitting a
message warden Moore Gordon Moore that's
right yeah one of the founders of
hewlett-packard I think ah yeah yeah oh
boy you put me on the spot here
was it either that mr. tech journalists
and or Fairchild Semiconductor I'm okay
anyway but you know that you know the
issue when the wires are so small and
they react atomic distances right then
quantum effects between wires start
taking that's very sweet
it is sweet that it's independent of the
wires sitting next to it absolutely
because the wave function is that's to
the both say yeah so they're essentially
having to figure out how to make things
faster without making them smaller okay
so fine so even if you do level off at
Moore's law are they're fine but
presumably design can change
are there other limits price natural
yeah sure design at the moment actually
weirdly one of the big limits is how
fast can you get data to that device
from like a cell phone tower right you
know like that's almost a bigger limit
now than the speed of the phone that's
like cable TV that's right you know what
I mean like they talk about how great
your cable is we have this fiber-optic
and whatever that's like yeah still got
copper running into my house who gives a
damn it's like like I actually fell for
that crap and I was just like this is so
can we think of these smartphones as
augmenting our human physiology
absolutely sure I mean every technology
we've had has to a certain extent as
Marshall McLuhan put it be being an
extension of man right you know so TV
extended our vision the phone extended
our ability to speak and talk these
things are the strongest extensions of
humanity that we have ever had and I
would say that you could think of them
as almost like a sense apparatus they're
like a form of ESP by which we tap into
whatnot ESPN you could think of them as
a form of ESP by which we sense what
other people are thinking and talking
about and doing like all the time for
good and for ill right because on the
one hand wow you learn a lot of great
things on the other hand it's almost
like having telepathy and being able to
shut being unable to shut other people's
voices off in your head in fact when I
tweet and I look at the responses to
that - I usually tweet something yeah
educational that's my intent and I try
to add a little funny and if I can to
middle okay so I look at the response to
it and that informed I see that as a
neurosynaptic snapshot of the
instantaneous reaction to words I use to
phrases I compose to ideas I put out
there and then when I give a public talk
I fold those in and I'm a way better
communicator
that's my ESP in a sense yeah getting
inside the head of you know a million
people I just figured out I'm doing
Twitter all wrong
coming up more of my interview with
Marquez and it's and all in his capacity
to tell us what's going down
technology spectrum when Startalk
returns
back on Startalk I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson
co-host Chuck nice in studio guest today
Clive Thompson a tech writer for the New
York Times and wired and then other
venues a few others do a few others a
few others we featuring my interview
with marques Brownlee he's a a
twenty-something early 20s reviewer of
tech devices that you might think of
getting he does this on the internet has
millions of followers and so I got here
sort of a interesting sort of
perspective okay on what role this this
portable technologies might play today
so I just had to ask him what that
relationship was cool between these
technologies and our lives just check it
out you've only really ever known the
Internet as a thing in your life rather
than having to have transitioned from
walking to the library to get
information and data yeah so to you your
life is practically define enabled by
information you get on the internet what
those apps do for you as you conduct
your life so there's a certain mount of
trust that you place in this information
in the integrity of this information I
have an app on my phone called Google
now and if I go to class enough times
with my phone in my pocket it knows that
I go there every day
so it puts that down as where I work but
it knows I go there every day and if
it's far enough away that I Drive there
every day it'll start to show me a card
in the morning of when I should leave
based on traffic to get there on time
because I go there the same time every
day so now it's helping me get there on
time because it knows where I go every
day if there's an accident but the watch
will wake me up earlier to tell me you
should hit on head out earlier because
there's an accident on the road there's
an accident on the road you're about to
take to get to the place you're about to
go and okay with all this I'm ok with
all of it because it's helping me if
there you know this people don't like to
think that you know Google knows all
this about us they're gonna use this
information or even the machines that
are collecting the information can turn
and use it I feel like if they're giving
back this information to help me in this
way that's actually really useful
I'm okay with it so I'm the senior
citizen among the three of us in my day
privacy was paramount absolutely and I
don't know that this next generation
gives a rat's ass about privacy not all
their stuff is on internet we're at wet
Dawei you know the height their weight
their sexual preference their their
gender pronoun and can you just offer
some reflections on the meaning of
privacy in the era of quote helpful yeah
helpful it's definitely changed a lot
for exactly the reasons we've been
talking about it is sort of impossible
if you're young right now to have a
social life without participating in you
know all these apps you know your social
apps social apps exactly like whether
that's snapchat or Facebook or whatever
you're kind of off the grid yeah and
there are there are abstainers it's kind
of funny you will find young people who
are like I will have no truck with this
but they're the ones who are like kind
of that iconic class who don't really
care about you know about having you
know a big a big group of friends so I
think one of the problems young people
have is that like they're it's not it's
not even necessarily that they have a
fundamentally different attitude towards
privacy but they have no choice but to
do these types of things in the same way
that maybe for us when we were younger
you know not getting a driver's license
was sort of basically a vow of I'm never
going anywhere that the cool kids are
going right you know you could have said
hey I think I grew up in New York City
yeah okay in Toronto Drive yeah yeah and
so you know if you get back then that if
you opted out from that technology you
had a real social trouble right so these
are cultural social forces we operate
absolute and if you're in the middle of
it you don't even know that there was
another option yeah but my problem is
that there is it you heard in his
statement was resident a certain amount
of trust in the responsibility that
Google has yeah yeah he's trusting these
do you trust all right what's your trust
level Wow
you know I don't trust anybody that's
the other thing
not in a conspiracy way it's just I
don't want you knowing this about me
because it's power and we all know power
corrupts no job without you it has power
you see you know I Franklin for sound
like old people are not
the only way this could have got worse
here's Google okay especially the black
community here's Google if it had been
invented 25 years ago Google in the
black community your damn business
Franklin Ford's came up with a book he
talks about big tech right and he means
the great big huge companies to have
massive amounts of power you know
Facebook Apple Microsoft and Google and
he makes a distinction between that and
like kind of smaller tech which are
companies you might actually know and
trust and I think that's a good
distinction because you know what you
guys are not but all those big ones used
to be little don't tell me you know I I
could just big now I agree but like so
the problem we can write the problem
yeah but they're they're small tech you
can completely trust like you know open
source stuff like the Tor project right
right their whole point is to try and
make it easier but you'd have privacy
online and it's open source and it's a
it's like a you know run for nonprofit
civic minded hackers there is technology
out there that you can trust it's not
the stuff that is big and is you know
rewarded heavily by that by the by the
market it's all about the commercial
entity is anything is there anything out
there that you've said yeah all right
that crosses the line oh yeah sure I'll
give you an example like so there was um
I came home from a summer vacation and I
opened up my android phone and Google
said hey you know we just put together a
slideshow of photos and like points on a
map of all that I'd done the last two
weeks just cuz we thought you might like
it and it was so creepy it was I think
it was super creepy and and I always
turn my locations off right okay but
sometimes you forget yeah and where I
got that same doggone slideshow and they
freaked me out it doesn't matter
I'll tell you why why I'll tell you why
oh that's as I understand it yeah okay
can't Google now if you put your picture
up in the cloud and it can do an image
recognition of your surroundings yeah
compared with soldiers and say this in
the plaza de Piazza of the DA and shall
we'd ID it that way absolutely in fact
actually if you ask you said if ik like
of course if you
me for the technology right now that
most unsettles me
it's the galloping roll out of face
recognition technology into everything
in table and so I'm like you know I
don't want my microwave you know
recognizing my face you know I don't
want on the present face recognition all
over the place
but it's getting so easy to do right
that you I mean just the other day
Google helpfully said hey guys we just
made tensorflow
our AI framework so it can run on like
basically a Raspberry Pi yeah that's
crazy saying there your guy the way and
let me tell you selves something else
this here's what really scares me about
the facial recognition yeah aside from
the fact that I don't like you said I
don't want my microwave recognizing my
face you know is the fact that once
somebody learns how to hack that and
make my face they're like face off yeah
okay now they could just walk around and
be me however as I understand it it's
not just it's better than what you would
think it's better than how you would do
thinking that you're looking at yourself
because it's actually measuring ratios
of dimensions of your face that are
extremely hard to do oh no I'm not
talking about the I'm talking about
going beyond the actual facial
recognition where that I go in and tell
well the software that so I don't grass
tyson i have so now everywhere neil
degrasse where everywhere I go this
brings us to because you can't out
program it you can just hack it in the
backend always go around oh this brings
me to the concept of internet identity
mm-hmm okay who are you on the internet
and how and privacy breaches this sort
of thing and so so I had to ask him
marques Brownlee just is the internet
not only helping us but now defining us
defining our identities and what is kind
of dude let's say let's check out the
interview so is your life being defined
by what all the ways the internet
inserts its way into your into your
routine because in my generation it's
still
it's a luxury it's a convenience it's a
tool it is not me it has it become you
so I I would say yes the Internet is
part of our life and always has been in
a way that other generations exist
alongside the Internet and may go over
and use it once in a while I feel like
everything we do now whether it's
communication or sharing anything with
anyone whether it's someone I know or
just posting something for the world all
of it goes through the internet the
convenience stuff like I said we're a
normal going to work routine would have
no internet involved in it in 1990 today
it's relying upon Google Maps and and my
alarm clock on my phone and everything
telling me when to wake up and when to
leave and how to get there so in that
way I do think we are completely tuned
into the Internet in a way that's not
the same as any other generation yeah
but can I say it's not that so much you
are tuned into the Internet the
Internet's tuned into you that also is
true do you have an identity outside of
how you are represented on the Internet
you've got a Facebook page this is what
I am this this is how I want the world
to see it's almost like a pair of
identities where you you have your
social life but you have your social
media life as well and sometimes they're
different you'd be surprised how
different they are with a single person
having an online life versus an offline
life which is kind of weird okay how
close are the two for you for me I'm the
same person will be the judges will be
the judge it's all the same yes so I
wonder if one of my favorite comics from
was 1990s New Yorker there's a dog at
the computer you know the one I'm
talking about and when he says to the
dog next to him good thing about the
internet no one knows you're a dog
that's pretty awesome so so what does it
mean and how real is it for people to
just have a dual identity the internet
identity and then their actual
themselves don't bite that off first I
mean we've always had multiple
identities in fact you know in the in
the early 20th century in late 19th
century my
raishin of people from small towns to
cities and one of the things I loved
about it was in the in the small town
everyone knew your business and it was
sort of impossible to reinvent yourself
or to discover other sides yourself
because I was like no that's not who you
really are I know who you are glad
Thompson right you go to the big city
and suddenly it's like lo and behold wow
I could be someone differently I want or
I could be a couple of different people
and one person at work and then I go off
and I do my thing with my crab there's a
quick thing there people who say the
city is so crowded I want to go out into
a rural suburban area where no one will
know me ya know it's the opposite they
will figure you out in 15 minutes yes
yes where's the city right no one gives
a cares too many right right so I think
I think multiple identities is actually
healthy uh uh and and a good thing
frankly I'm just said repeat that I
think having multiple identities you
know as long as they're not you know
sociopathic and you have like a
different postal box where you where you
sort of you know
anyway the that's healthy and and
there's an extent to which I think you
see people trying to do that online and
kind of failing because large
corporations don't want you to have that
they want to know everything about you
they want to assemble it all in one
place so they can target ads at you like
in India's Mark Zuckerberg her original
statement of Facebook cause you know
having different selves as a sign of
inauthenticity and of course he's gonna
say that because he wants to have
everything about you speaking target ads
at you right now and but what he's where
he's I was about to say failing
miserably but then I thought probably
this is Who I am and I'm saying that
he's failing then so that doesn't make
sense but I think what he's not taking
into account is the fact that when you
do have your different selves
they can also be authentic sure
absolutely have different cells that are
authentic self that's my point see like
I I play and I plain bands I'm a
journalist often those two creds have no
idea about the other part of me right
like and when I go and hang with
musicians someone don't read the stuff I
do they're just that's Clive the guitar
player right you know exactly right so
it's ultimately are there legal
ramifications to access to your private
information well I mean that's a good
question I'm
a lawyer who reads the the yeah you know
yeah that the disclaimer there's the
legal disclaimer that when you and I
always thought that when you click yes I
agree that some type of really weird
things should happen like you hear a
knock on the door and somebody's like
yeah we're here for your wife
what yeah man when you click that agree
that's crazy stuff the I mean I so I'm
not a lawyer so I'm not gonna give you a
good legal answer but but it's
definitely true that I think one of the
big issues right now is like you know
what what protections legal protections
do we have for the way our date is used
right now over in Europe they actually
have a much different view Germany
particularly because they have the Stasi
right so they are there they have a lot
of laws and Google runs against these
and hates them and lobbies against them
you know I think I think we probably
need much much better protections in
this content and should an employer hold
your social media life against you I
don't think they should know I don't
really don't think they should most of
the time particularly the hiring level
right yeah that's what I'm talking about
yeah sure a lot of hiring okay and then
they say say it what are they posted and
what drunken pictures yeah you know I
don't think I don't think I don't think
that they should be doing that stuff
because that would that's tantamount to
be in the pre-internet era say hey can
we come home and just rummage around you
know and that you know that was that was
considered unreasonable back then it it
should be similarly considered
unreasonable man so I'm a comedian today
all my stuff on social media I can't get
a job tell jokes about sadly we gotta
take a break but coming up more on the
future of technology
when Startalk returns
back on Startalk and I've got my expert
guest Wired magazine in New York Times
columnist Clive Thompson we're talking
about the future of technology Chuck
nice nice hi sir
so we're not experts at this but we have
strong opinions on it yes and he's got
expertise so we're good and we're
featuring my interview with marques
Brownlee he's the twenty one twenty two
twenty twenty something year old who's
been reviewing technology for everybody
on the internet and YouTube in
particular with millions of clips so I
had to ask him where does he think
technology is headed let's check it out
what are you gonna be telling your kids
what'd he say back in my day when I was
22 look what we had to do oh my god can
I have sympathy please honestly I'm
thinking cars I'm hoping cars how we
drive cars today and we know those would
be really big gadget does that count as
something you wouldn't I count that I'm
into car tech I've done a couple of
videos about cars and that's what I am
so not just handheld you yeah anything
electronic I T digital gadget I say
anything with an on button is game
technically not every car has an on
button but if you look at some of the
more high-end cars today they've got
electric systems galore plenty of high
tech I feel like a lot of the stuff we
have now that's inside of a car that you
have to control like the steering wheel
even if you're in a self-driving car
they still want you at the controls in
case something might go wrong because
it's a computer and it's a system that's
funny because that the fact that you say
that implies that something would go
wrong with the machine that the human
can correct rather than something going
wrong with a human and the Machine needs
to correct yeah because last I checked
all those accidents on the street or
humans messing up fresh air but even the
systems getting to the point where
everyone has a car that is capable of
driving itself no one even needs that
space of a steering wheel in the car you
just kind of sit down it's maybe a bench
facing another bench and you just kind
of ride along to your destination I feel
like that's way down the road where
we're at the point where a car is sort
of fusing into the next generation of
vehicle at this point so if cars do all
the driving on the road then in
principle you can up the speed limit
right yeah
there you're not at risk of reaction
time exactly because electrons react
much faster than and he hewed the human
brain even though their electrons in
there somewhere but wired for reacting
to traffic patterns a car can way
outperform a human right so I'm
imagining you go 150 200 miles an hour
driving down the road no problem and
they'll just weave interest seamlessly
within each other in a way that would be
scary if a human was trying to do it
that's right because if all the cars are
going 200 any high speed yeah then it's
a moving coordinate system so that a car
can move in and out of that that's the
other thing all the cars are sort of
talking to each other as as points in
the major sort of avoid each other
because they already know if car all the
way on the right lane with a bunch of
stuff in between it knows it wants to go
to the left and car all the way on the
left and knows it wants to go to the
right and they can tell the cars around
it I'm trying to go to the right I'm
trying to go to the left human couldn't
do that with another car on the other
side of the road no you can home try but
those those machines can work with each
other much more efficiently I never
considered that yeah so it's it's a it's
it's a ballet on the freeway to Symphony
Symphony it's beautiful that's beautiful
that's really beautiful but you know why
do we get software updates because
they're bugs that are found by the many
users that often the testing is just
let's put it out there and see what
comes back right so self-driving cars
where lives are at risk what is the risk
of there being some kind of bug where it
kills people or or on top of that what's
the risk of hacking into a car to create
the accident in the first place I think
the hacking might be a bigger risk in
the bugs
I mean regulatorily it's gonna be tricky
for them to get those cars on the road
because cars are pretty tightly
regulated unless they can demonstrate
you know pretty persuasive there's not a
lot of bugs now hacking is a different
thing because now you've got a human
person that trying actively to break
something right and that's a much more
volatile risk there's already been
situations where cars are out there and
you know wired did wired hired a couple
of hackers to literally take over car
what's going on the highway and they did
a little table that's right
so um so I think I've driven in
self-driving cars in diabolical division
exactly exactly yeah the no I've read
I've ridden in Google self-driving cars
felt pretty comfortable they're actually
in weird way they're almost what a
cautious driver it's like it's like
being there with your grandmother at the
other wheel right now could get faster
as you point out but um overall you know
if I were to compare it to the dangers
of humans driving cars I'm probably okay
you know with the self-driving cars if
it's well regulated that's the big if
right so that's the future I think so
yeah I mean III think it might be it
might take longer than we think you're
getting these rosy predictions of five
years yeah I don't see five you know no
but the fact is that they are on the
road right now they do work which I
forget that trucking company bottle auto
yeah so now Auto has gone cross-country
traverse the country several times with
their with their semi and the only thing
the human being is doing is monitoring
they have a guy that sits there and
monitors that in it and you could also I
mean frankly the reason I'm kind of in
favor of it is it has potentially great
environmental benefits right because you
get way less idling you get way less
jackrabbit starts these are things that
burn huge amounts rapid start you know
when you're just your ear you're at rest
and you suddenly burst off right as
humans humans want accelerate fast robot
cars like more humans getting ease
forward testosterone infused boy humans
I could I didn't learn how to drive till
I was 25 and that's after the the boy
human testosterone forces right have
dissipated Oh nicely done yeah yeah it
was very and any get lowered voice did
not be able to do anything until there's
let's be honest it would three men
sitting here we know the deal we go
right here under 25 and you have a penis
you're effing crazy that's all there is
to it okay there's something deeply
wrong with you you need help you should
talk to somebody okay so what intrigues
me is when you have a self-driving car
and it's talking to other cars there are
signals there's I just learned that the
Tesla is talks are there Tesla's so if
you come on to a bumpy road
and then you make the adjustment to
change your suspension which of course
you can do that information goes to the
next Tesla any other Tesla that will be
on that road and it will pre adjust the
suspension before it enters the bumpy
part of the see this is where the stuff
just gets creepy man this is what I'm
talking about this walk to your car to
know what my car talking to no other car
strangers car ok stranger danger I don't
want that Tesla's just wanna know if
there's our hazard in the road know what
I don't want is that other Tesla saying
you know your owner doesn't love you ok
and and the interesting points going to
be will there come a point when the
government decides that the self-driving
cars are so much safer that it's illegal
for a human to drive a car they could
surely do that however I've thought
about this yeah it's not you cannot take
a horse on the interstate right even
though there's a day when horses were
the only things that you around in point
so now if you like horses you go to a
stables right yeah for you to exactly
I'll have racetrack we have racetracks
where then if you still a sports car
collector right and you want to control
your own car you take it to the sports
that you have a birth at the sports
track right at this at the driving track
and that's where you drive and you get
your thrills just like the horseback
riders do so the Mustang will just be
just like a real Mustang and pull your
Mustang out of the garage to take it for
a ride giddyup oh man I just I asked
marques is there any any other future of
technology that he's excited about or
intrigued by let's check it out
when you're the ripe old age of 32 how
do you want to be living life what what
technology do you want to be surrounding
you 10 years from now I hope I hope car
Tech is on another level I hope that's
the most exciting part and that's the
right horizon for this to kick in it's
gonna do it all right
I hope the the handheld devices we have
are no longer handheld and that's pretty
ambitious for 10 years I think but but
we're relation very well someone would
argue they're like in your arm or like
attached you've seen wearable tech
smartwatches they kind of shrink down
and and end up on your wrist or on your
ear and on your neck or something like
that but how about the biology
technology interface interviewing yeah
it's a little USB thing right here yeah
they kind of did that in and that no one
called it that but they were they were
USB ponytails and in Avatar remember
that's where they take their hair and
they plug it into the night land yeah
yeah and they would communicate with one
another
yeah USB ponytail that's what that was
yeah that's the kind of thing I see
though is like a much more portable but
complete version of your your digital
self to just exist and be able to move
around it so Clive is this how real is
this interface of biology and technology
and I ask because do I need my iPhone
neurologically attached to me when it's
sitting at my fingertips to begin with I
mean it's not the same thing it's it's
awfully intimate right now right it's
it's right there it's completely yeah
they talk about wearable technology we
already have wearable technology we've
all grown up carrying phones with us
right it's in my pocket
you know but there's people working on
you know Google's working on these you
know like contact lenses that have like
technology display technology and them
they're working on that quite seriously
but any ethical frontiers here that we
don't know about yet bioethical I mean
that the bioethical frontiers concerns
are always do you produce something
that's great for intelligence
performance and ability but is it so
expensive the only rich people get it
right I heard a rebuttal to that from
Ray Kurzweil because we had him on
Startalk yeah all right he said no
that's not a problem
they have Zinta have not and I said why
he said because when it first comes out
it never works well anyway and it's
stupendously expensive and it's not and
and so yes only a few people have it but
only when it becomes mass-market or does
it become truly functional right when
phones first came out you know you had
to be pretty rich - yeah the first
computers are pretty first computers
they're useless and the first phones are
completely useless and the ones that are
mass-market are the ones that are most
so that's why I don't see that as a
problem well I mean I hope he's right
shall we say yeah yeah yeah so climb
some great haven't you yeah it's not
great being on to a conversation guys
and we got to
bring you back will surely find some
other excuse you're much better than the
other right well cool Chuck any any
final thoughts here no I just think that
this is a very scary time I'm sorry
technology is wonderful and I'm so happy
that we have it yes and we I think the
human race is so much better off now
that we're all have our faces stuck in
some stupid phone instead of talking to
one another you know I think I think we
don't I think we are still in our
infancy do you know it took multiple
centuries after the printing press
before anyone figured out that you could
make something call the newspaper true
so it was you have broadsheets and
things but at a routine leap produced
newspaper yeah that was took like four
hundred years I have 300 something years
so here we are at the dawn of the
Internet even though it's 10 15 20 years
old I think we don't yet know we're
still playing with ourselves right and I
don't think we have we have I think
there's a level of maturity of how to
use the power of this technology that we
have yet to attain I just love that you
said level of maturity after you said
playing with yourself and I'm standing
here like the number one thing that the
internet causes so I just think there's
a there's a level of technological
maturity that we have yet to achieve and
I don't know when is it 50 years is it a
hundred years 150 years
I don't know but only then can we really
say that it doesn't own us we you've
been watching and probably more likely
listening to Startalk and I've been your
host Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist
Chuck thanks for being here always a
pleasure live good idea and I'll publish
thanked marques Brownlee for agreeing to
that interview and until next time as
always I bid you
[Music]